- [Narrator:] They went too far.
- We've made some powerful enemies, Daniel.
- CONTROLLED FURY!
Mrs. Ford, do I have permission...
to go for it?
Kill them all, MC/DC.
- God, I love this program.
- Oh, we’re hugging now.
- [Narrator:] They knew too much.
- [Goodell:] We have one job here in the league.
- To keep the Lions out of the playoffs.
- You told me this draft class was a B at best.
- The Swift trade, the Gibbs pick?
I just couldn't see it.
- YOU FOOL!
- [Narrator:] They played too fast.
- Hey, keep up that rhythm, kid.
- And you keep playing that sweet...sweet...bruise...
- [Narrator:] Against all odds.
- He's ready, sir.
A third franchise QB in a row for the Pack.
- This will surely take down
those disgusting Lions.
- Just give me, like, one second to get it together.
- [Narrator:] One Pride...
- [Campbell:] Password.
- [Sewell:] Blueberries.
- Reporting for duty...
again.
- [Narrator:] on an impossible mission...
- [Phone Voice:] Who’s out to get ya?
- The refs, the commish, the Pro Bowl voters, everyone drafte-
- Alright, man. We get it.
- [Narrator:] To restore the roar.
- TONIGHT. WE DINE.
ON RAM!
DETROIT
- ...and the surrounding suburbs!
- VERSUS EVERYBODY!
- [Narrator:] The Detroit Lions in...
- [Voice:] You stole my legacy, Goff.
- You stole mine first.
- [Voice:] Hope you don't mind.
I still had the key.
- [crowd cheers]
- [Stafford:] Thank you!
- [Narrator:] Oh, Detroit fans are giving Stafford a standing ovation.
What class.
- [Stafford blows kiss]
- [Narrator:] They thought he was dead.
- What? No. I've been down the Shore.
Also, I was on the Jets last year.
- [Narrator:] Forgotten by all.
- You'se all know I won a Super Bowl, right?
- [Narrator:] Mighty Joe Old
- I'm 38.